hi I'm Jamie Lynn Spears and we're the
cast of Zoey 101 and we're going to give
our Zoey 101 opinions with busty pick
another Nickelodeon show for Zoey 101 to
cross over with Drake and Josh
iCarly Big Time Rush or the obvious
choice Victorians
I mean yeah Victoria's for sure see what
she was still up to after they finished
school it's like what I have a strong
vote for victorious
so I was thinking Big Time Rush I would
get to have one of those moments like
Jamie
Velma stump being herself and being
Jamie cuz I was Camille on Big Time Rush
and then also no one imagined a like a
split screen moment where in both of
these character is talking to myself
yeah that would be a cool moment we
gotta do both it's no big deal
who was Zoey's best roommate Dana Lola
or Nicole Dana I wasn't what about Quinn
she was always doing something
entertaining like whether she was
experimenting or whether she was you
know creating I just always had
something going on so I sneaked as a
roommate like it might have been
annoying at the time if you were truly
you know in real life but for me I just
think that like that was like the best
storylines came out of some of the stuff
Quinn would be doing in the room of
those options
I'll definitely select Dana Wow I feel
like such a winner here thanks guys a
lot of episodes a lot of unusual
episodes dedicated to her doing
something a little out there
I love always experiment on me so I feel
like I was who was the better boyfriend
to Quinn Logan Marc del piccolo oh oh my
gosh I gotta go Marc del piccolo there
I'm sorry I
right you deserve better is literally a
one it was a growing man and Logan was
the better II don't know he was but
let's feast they had that fire at that
passion who was a better kisser mark or
me and had that fire with Logan so I'm
gonna say Logan Oh
and then also Aaron is going to
reference the day that you would not
take our kissing scene seriously and
continued to lick the side of my face
you didn't brush your teeth whether or
not it was true you thought that was
hilarious
I specifically remember somebody like
eating onions before I could kissing
scene it was either Aaron or Matt wasn't
mad never me I take that seriously mark
was just nothing honestly though I loved
him on the show and I loved him as a
person right but I feel like he was like
literally she was gonna end up killing
him
he was like her like a mouse that she
like tested everything on if you can
only pick one piece a adult to come back
to his Zoey 101 reboot who would you
pick cocoa bean rivers kazoo her nurse
cruncher was right he played he was in
Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift Dean
rivers is such an angry old guy I kind
of love him you know I like you man Coco
I do I can't choose but I just think
Coco like a lot of people really loved
her and yeah especially like as she got
older like see where her life took her
like I really am interested there's a
lot to unpack there
I think rivers is in jail what and
you're what's already got new a little
bit of trouble team chase or Tim James
gene chase yeah it's gotta be chase yes
very nice okay these come on specimen I
understand
come on I think that as far as the
storyline
chase all the way but like we obviously
love James and we love Austin but like
for Zoey it's gotta be chase
there's no Zoey without Zoey in Chase
which was the best episode of zoey 101
school dance time capsule which is of
course a classic little beach party pc a
confidential quarantine which you know
appropriate right and then we have
goodbye Zoey season three it's me in the
field for sure sorry but she's grandma
is the best episode yeah by the way
every morning to run in everyday yeah I
like what I think about our experience
little beach party was like it was I
mean we just hang out on the beach and
it was like that's like what I think
about Zoey and it was just I think like
the experience for a little beach party
was the most fun shooting like the
experience I think as far as like the
overall episode probably good buzz oh he
was like more impactful hug like you
know a story to it as far as what was
happening with our characters as they
were growing so I'd say that was
probably better episode but its period
so as I guess like little beach party
was obviously a lot of fun which Quinn
vention do you wish was real banal
a hundred percent healthy potato chips
breath freshener tongue vacuum plasma
bolt wrap or Fras I would have to say
100% healthy potato chicken yeah sure
crazy without the side effects yeah yeah
they decided thanks trying to get ready
for a wedding while your favorite snack
is potato chips just does not work out I
gotta go to crash because we're all
older and we're gonna need to energy for
the reboot I want to believe that Quinn
has the ability to successfully make
something like that
wait what is it what was that one okay I
could be completely wrong we didn't have
something with the ghost of PCA and she
was like trying to catch the plasma oh
yeah you are basically the Ghostbusters
right yeah yeah I see I got it I could
like
vote for Quinn to be ghostbusters right
that would be obviously the best option
that would be pretty sweet
which of these iconic couples do you
still think are together today Quinn and
Logan so Ian chase Lisa and Michael none
of the above
hope is Joey and cheese listen the
quitted logan thing intrigues me Quinn
and Logan I mean especially Logan has
had a lot of time to grow and become who
we could actually be like the guy I'm
looking at right now Matthew you know
and and and perhaps there's room for
some sort of beautiful relationship to
blossom there Lisa and Michael also a
no-brainer I never saw any any reason to
doubt that that would go beautifully
Zoey a genius
maybe in the long run yeah in the long
run creature thing Zoey and chase
probably do a lot of back and forth but
I think in the end like we all hope that
they're together yeah I think that
Michael and Lisa like they were so
stable they're like almost baby it got
stagnant so like they were just like a
like weeds runs course and then I think
that Logan and Quinn I think that they
just probably had this like bizarre love
for each other that like they couldn't
like they probably don't really get
along but they just do that's like kind
of what makes it work you know what I
mean I want to see like a winning Logan
like a Blair and gossip girl
relationship whether it's just like
exactly what I picture to be completely
honest you had any lemonade so as far as
who are still together I don't know
what's up in the air I'm interested in
where those relations were taken like
I'm interested to see what happens along
the way when Quinn Quinn vents something
and Logan realizes he can profit
like carbon why quit was interested in a
minute reading by him is because he
treats her different than everybody else
for better or worse like he doesn't uh
treat her with kid gloves you know what
I mean and like again her a chance to
really fight back and I feel like she
got to step into her own by by pushing
back against and I feel like it helps
her grow like you're please him grow
yeah I think you were good a lot of no
job for you